[DRUMS PLAYING]
Yeah, yeah!
Ah, the coffee's kicking in.
Yeah!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a tempo to life.
There's a tempo to every song.
You can lift the band,
and the band can lift you.
In The Beatles, it was
like being psychic.
We knew what to do, and we
loved to do it with each other.
Best band I ever was in.
I love to play.
I love to sit behind
those buggers.
It fills a lot of my soul.
[DRUMS PLAYING]
You know, the way I play is
sort of a purposeful way.
When it gets to the
chorus, go to the bell.
I still do to this day
because it raises it up.
You got to work for the verses.
But the chorus, you can rock.
With the bass drum, once I've
hit it, that's what I've done.
Some people, like--
[DRUMS PLAYING]
--deaden it.
Off.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The dream of being a
drummer came when I was 13.
I was in hospital.
I had tuberculosis.
To keep us busy,
a music lady would
come in with percussion
things-- maracas, triangles.
She gave me a little, teeny
drum the first time she came in.
And something came
over me that I
knew this is what I want to do.
If I can give you
anything to take away,
you just got to love
what you're doing,
and you've got to
do it your way.
And it doesn't matter if
there's 40,000 or 40 people,
you've just got to get
yourself some friends and play.
The more you play,
the better life is.
[DRUMS PLAYING]
I'm Ringo Starr, and
this is MasterClass.